[Musique]
j'ai pas la prétention est présente dans
le public
nous poursuivons trois objectifs le
premier c'est que ce message celui de la
ruralité celui des exclus celui des
délaissés soit pris en compte par les
deux candidats qui seront en lice au
second tour deuxième objectif c'est que
effectivement que nous dépassions le
score d'un million deux cent mille voix
ce qu'ont réalisé aux élections
européennes épi le troisième objectif
c'est bien entendu d'être candidat aux
élections législatives
parce que chacun sait que président
depuis que qui sera élu au sénat mais le
5 mai le représentera rien s'il n'a pas
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale
or nous voulons changer les choses et
pour changer les choses il faut que nous
rendre plus que nous entrions à
l'assemblée nationale alors tout le
reste c'est du monument quand je vois
tous ces candidats à la présidentielle
la plupart se ancien brillant de la
république ancien premier ministre
ancien ministre il va nous expliquer ce
qu'il veut le faire dans une heure ou
deux heures mais ils ne font rien parce
qu'il n'avait qu'à le faire quand il
était au gouvernement
or je trouve que c'est une grande
duperie moi j'ai pas de prétention la
prétention que j'ai c'est de défendre
les délaisser les exclus arrivé à mettre
une grande loi l'aménagement du
territoire afin que le service public
élément de cohésion territoriale élément
de cohésion sociale soit on verra tout
le monde alors qu'aujourd'hui
ben nos grands cadors de la politique
sont en train de nous expliquer qu'il
faut démanteler et si j'arrive à faire
comprendre aux politiques qu'ils doivent
avoir acquis sur terre être les élus de
proximité
s'ils comprennent qu'il faut qu'il faut
s'occuper du quotidien des gens eh bien
je serais plus heureux les hommes et
ensuite j'espère que nous défendrons ce
que nous défendons dans cette élection
la preuve d'indifférence
[Musique]